[Musique]
t'as pas déterminer sa non consent le
vin sans courage pour le courage mais je
me réserve pour la finale sous les 10
degrés du matin non pas démotiver les
fidèles du trail de la chaloupe 23 km
entre le village de la chaloupe et la
mer en boucle partant de lui soumettre
d'ici pour arriver à 1000 mètres et puis
redescende à cinq mètres en bas pour
remonter à 826
[Musique]
après la traversée de la route
départementale 3 la cote calme toutes
les ardeurs transports mais l'ambiance
des eaux illustre la dynamique sociale
de ces manifestations sportives le
programme faut faire un bon temps pas de
soucis quoi le temps le bon là il est
super c'est la journée la france qui ait
ce soir en plus ce soir oui oui a pas de
souci ça couvre à gagner de toute façon
la france doit gagner et on va faire la
fête
pères super les premiers sauts partiale
et vitesse folle
non ce n'est pas vous c'est incroyable
ce jour nouveau ils sont devant ils sont
pas si l' on y va aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une succession de paysages riches
d'histoire au milieu d'un développement
démographique de ces micro région à
travers ses sentiers ce territoire
montre en tout cas son plus beau jour
mais quoi si vous voulez décembre vous
êtes bientôt arriver mais j'avais vu sur
quoi mon marché la cenc épaves et passer
un bout d'histoire ça est vrai qu'à
saint leu on a vraiment une chance parce
que il ya toute une histoire à raconter
y ait par exemple 7 maisons
elle a aujourd'hui deux tours avec une
belle façade de warrants mais il faut
imaginer qu avant 1800 c'était
simplement un poste de vigie de tours
une passerelle vigie pourquoi pour
surveiller la rade qu'on a sur saint leu
et au moment de la guerre des anglais
c'est une occasion justement pour
pouvoir ensuite donné l'alertent
batterie les sans culottes
[Musique]
et à ce jeu de gros coeur dans ce
dénivelé impressionnant c'est les locaux
qui ont gagné le centre c'est cayenne
sentiront peut faire le test de vitesse
107 saint-leu arrivé à la chaloupe d'une
traite que
c'est cool il ya un test et mauges
patients testés mois et à saint lô nf à
saint denis
colorado 6 fera
ouais c'est cool comme je connais un
petit peu le terrain de jeu et non du
coup c'est vraiment là au pâturage
c'est un petit peu difficile mais j'ai
mon petit bonhomme là c'est lui qui m'a
donné la force est une maman rahman une
coupe aux antilles pour vivre la course
de l'intérieur et découvrir bien
d'autres choses
retrouvez votre émission terre de trail
à la rencontre de ces territoires des
hauts de l'ouest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]